you knew though you did nothing
[Music]
are you doing yeah your grandma tells me
programs on some fainting environment
lawyer down in Cincinnati I am a
corporate defense attorney so I defend
chemical companies
well now you can defend me how many did
you lose one hundred ninety a hundred
and ninety cows you tell me nothing's
wrong here it's a small matter for a
family friend help a guy I need to a
farmer or you
that's chemicals I'm telling ya I'm
seeing documents I don't understand
they're hiding something that chemical
what if you drank it drank it it's like
saying what if I swallowed a tire
what if whatever's killing those cows is
in the drinking water
[Music]
at DuPont better living through
chemistry it's our DNA you need to tell
me what the hell's going on
DuPont is knowingly poisoning 70,000
local residents for the last 40 years we
knew still you did nothing you want to
flush your career down the toilet for
some cowhand you want to take everything
that you know and turn it against an
iconic American company like an
informant isn't that right
isn't that right isn't that right yes
they have all the money all the
firepower and they'll use it I know I
was one of them
our government is captive to DuPont
they're trying to force you to make me
stop
he was willing to risk his job his
family for a stranger who needed his
help the system is rigged they want us
to think it'll protect us we protect us
we do
you
you